The first 28 minutes of saving private
Ryan are devoted to the bloody allied
invasion of Omaha beach on June six,
1944.
The scene is rightly regarded as one of
the best battle scenes in film history.
Thanks to a brutal and unflinching
recreation by Steven Spielberg by
placing this extended scene right at the
start of the film,
it's clear that Spielberg's goal was to
drop the viewer right into the action
without warning a traumatic experience
that leaves the viewer on edge for the
rest of the movie and this way,
Spielberg mimics the exhaustion that the
allied soldiers had to fight through for
the entirety of their time at war,
but to create and realize the scenes,
Spielberg had to reconcile a fundamental
contradiction.
The sequence had to be chaotic and
coherent at the same time.
In other words,
the critical impression of the battle
should be one of randomness,
of violence and death occurring so
rapidly and indiscriminately at the mind
is bewildered.
It has no time to process,
but that randomness has to be
communicated cinematically via some sort
of structure,
a coherence that somehow leaves you with
the feeling of chaos.
What Spielberg is trying to do is fill
in two different kinds of gaps in our
knowledge about this historical moment.
First,
he wants to close the gap between
Hollywood's heroic depictions of World
War II and the vicious,
deeply harrowing experiences of those
who were actually there.
I mean even in strong depictions of the
Normandy landings like the great 1962
movie,
the longest day filmed entirely on
tripods.
The viewer's experience is still some
distance from the subjectivity of the
moment in saving private Ryan.
Spielberg wants to shrink that distance
as much
possible.
The other gaps Spielberg wants to close
is the one between what we know about
this event and what we've actually seen
of it.
There is extremely little footage of the
Normandy invasion on June six,
1944,
and almost none from the landing at
Omaha Beach,
and there are a lot of reasons for this.
A significant percentage of the
cameramen who filmed the war for the
allied powers were killed.
The remaining did their best to avoid
that same fate by finding places of
cover where they could film at a
distance.
For this reason,
you get a lot of footage from before the
landing at Normandy on the boats,
which Spielberg recreates in saving
private Ryan and a lot of footage after
the battle is over.
During the chaos,
cameramen were doing their best to keep
themselves and their cameras out of
danger.
Documentaries that Spielberg relied more
on were shot far from the Normandy
beaches,
specifically with the Marines at
Toronto,
which was shot in Japan,
and the battle for San Pietro,
which was made by the famous filmmaker,
John Houston.
It'll be watching that second film.
Spielberg was struck by how cameramen
always stayed low to the ground and how
the camera shook when an explosion went
off nearby as critic toby higgins notes,
Spielberg discovered that he adopted the
style of the battlefield.
Cameraman,
he could achieve a more subjective
experience of the war and that's exactly
what he did,
but the footage that I think has the
most impact on the Omaha beach scene is
John Ford's masterful war film.
The Battle of midway from 1942 in that
film forward brilliantly keeps in
moments when blasts affect the camera
gate or knock his hand held cameras back
and forth from this.
In some creative editing,
you get a much more visceral impression
of the battle,
so the essence of the idea for saving
private Ryan is here and it's obvious in
the battlefield camera approach,
but what's not so obvious is how
Spielberg takes this essence and injects
it with steroids.
For example,
one of the things that Spielberg does
that no actual war time camera man could
do is switch perspectives.
The Omaha beach scene functions from
three different perspectives,
the vantage of the invisible battlefield
cameraman,
the vantage of Tom Hanks and the vantage
of the German soldiers on the top of the
cliffs,
Spielberg alternates between these to
give a more 360 degree perspective on
the battle without losing any of the
immediacy.
That is his primary concern.
Even crazier.
It actually took me a few watches to
realize that this shot right here is
actually meant to be a moment inside Tom
Hanks head like the most intense first
person shooter game ever.
This kind of thing couched,
almost hidden in the middle of the rest
of the footage intensifies that feeling
of being there to its most extreme.
Maybe this is why the sequence triggered
actual ptsd and if you world war two
veterans who watched the film,
but the key to understanding how
Spielberg squares chaos with coherence
is in the amount of information that he
crammed into each shot.
The Omaha beach scene might seem like
the craziest,
fastest,
most intense sequence in the film,
but I counted the shots and the scene
that lasts exactly 24 minutes.
There are exactly 200 shots,
which means that every shot averages
seven point two seconds.
I mean that is an incredibly high
average for a scene like this and it
didn't seem right to me until I actually
went back and watched the scene with
this in mind.
You're asked to comprehend so much in
this Omaha beach scene,
so Spielberg eases the pressure on your
brain by panning,
tilting,
or moving the camera when others would
just cut.
This way.
You don't have to waste too much mental
energy on orienting yourself.
You can absorb the relevant information
as it comes,
and Spielberg is great at feeding you
relevant information as my friend Tony
wants remark.
This is a guy who loves to move the
camera with motivation,
so in a 12 second shot like this one,
you get a wide shot to close ups,
three inserts and the medium shot eight
pieces of information,
and the transitions here are really
great too.
He loves to start a long shot with the
action from the previous moment.
This is how he strings together all
these mini vignettes and it gives them a
forward momentum that keeps the viewer
on track.
Of course,
there's so much more to say about the
scene,
about the sound mixing and the lenses
and the de Saturation of the film stock,
about the costume design and the set
design,
but that's all been well covered before.
What inspires me about this scene is how
such a Maelstrom of action retains its
focus from end to end.
You can't just stage some insanity film,
a bunch of it from different angles and
hope to find a through line in the
editing a scene with an impact like
this,
something that you can revisit again and
again and find new things.
It takes real cinematic concentration.
In other words,
anyone can capture chaos,
but only the best can capture chaos with
clarity.
There is a new nerd writer video every
Wednesday,
so if you go right there to that box
that I've set up and click that,
you'll subscribe and get all the videos.
And,
and that is what helps me out the most.
It really is.
Um,
a couple of other things.
I'm way too back lit right now,
by the way,
I just launched the nerd writer.net,
which is my website.
You can find the videos there and asked
me questions and frequently asked
questions.
Is there.
So check that out.
Also Humpback on Instagram,
I don't really know why at the nerd
writer follow me there.
Some cool stuff.
I'll try not to post garbage pictures.
I might post some pictures of garbage,
but only if it's like artistic and
worthwhile.
Anyway,
I'll see you guys next Wednesday.